magie de la télé me voici revenu avec
vous titian cypher pendant qu'isabelle
mini continue tranquillement sa petite
décoration autour de nos feuilles glanés
en bourgogne franche comté et vous le
disais c'est un mois particulier oui 7
octobre rose mais c'est aussi le mois
des dys dyslexie par exemple mais pas
seulement et pour nos enfants
ça veut dire peut-être aller faire en
sorte que malgré tout il se penche sur
la lecture et vous avez sélectionné
quelques ouvrages pour nous oui je vous
en ai ramené pas mal parce que
figurez-vous que désormais on s'est dit
les éditeurs se sont dit on va pas
laisser 8 à 12 % des enfants et des
adultes éloigné de la lecture parce que
ça fait quand même pas mal en fait selon
les estimations n'est pas celui que vous
avez une pédiatre à koné ils ont envoyé
beaucoup deux enfants qui ont des
difficultés et du coup et ils ont
commencé à publier des livres
spécifiquement pour le public qui est
dyslexique et alors je vais juste vous
faire un petit rappel sur la dyslexie
parce que ce sont les troubles du
langage écrit mais si on n'est pas
touché on a parfois du mal à savoir de
quoi il s'agit alors ça peut être une
confusion entre des lettres qui seront
requis ce qui se ressemblent par exemple
b le décès c'est ce qu'on connaît le
mieux en fait ça peut être aussi la
difficulté à comprendre les phonèmes
composez vous savez le haut le ou le que
et du coup à ne pas les reconnaître
quand on les voit écrit on a pas
comprendre ce que ça produit comme son
ou à la difficulté à se concentrer sur
la fin des mots alors du coup quand on
lit c'est compliqué parce qu'on buts
avant la fin du mot ou sinon aussi avoir
du mal à appréhender des notions
complexes donc on y en mots compliqués
on n'arrive pas à comprendre et on se
dit je referme le livre m'a alors donné
sa voix à la volonté tout ça ah oui tout
à fait mais ce qui est important c'est
de les reconnaître ces enfants là dans
les classes et de ne pas dire qu'ils
sont nuls mais leur apprendre à
travailler avec des moyens adaptés à eux
mais ça tombe très bien parce que
justement stephen fry fort nous a trouvé
quelques bouquins qui peuvent servir à
nos enfants nos petits-enfants qui
peuvent parfois souffrir de ce trouble
alors qu'est-ce que vous avez
sélectionné bien du coup il ya plusieurs
éditeurs qui sont lancés vraiment là
dedans mais vraiment de manière très
sérieuse
et on va dire avec volontarisme
donc il ya un premier éditeur c'est
belin qu'à sa collection qui s'appelle
colibri mais il ya aussi nathan vous le
voyez qu'il publie beaucoup de livres
alors j'en ai amené pas mal y en a de
toutes sortes pour tous les niveaux ça
s'appelle dit school leur collection
douce comme voilà est en fait le point
commun de toutes ces collections c'est
que la mise en page est beaucoup plus
aéré vous le voyez ah oui alors on
publie pas des textes différents
pas forcément mais en tout cas on le
publie différemment la police de
caractère vous le voyez est aussi
beaucoup plus facile à lire en fête les
tec les lettres sont plus espacées se
détacher voilà détachées et puis on mais
aussi des lettres de différentes
couleurs pour que ça ressorte pour que
justement ce que je vous disais sur les
phonèmes ou la fin des mots puissent
être plus accessible que l'enfant se
disent ah ben il ya une fin des mollahs
je vais me concentrer dessus je vais y
arriver
et puis les mots compliqués on les met
directement en bas de page pour que
l'enfant ne se disent pas il faut que
j'aille chercher tout à la fin du livre
ce mot que j'ai pas compris je referme
le livre c'est fini et puis aussi vous
voyez comme c'est plus espacés on peut
faire des pauses au milieu d'un chapitre
on se dit pas vous savez comme le livre
un peu compliqué il faut que j'aille
absolument à la fin du chapitre et
cetera non là il n'y a pas de
culpabilité à avoir un livre on le lira
dix fois plus lentement qu'un bon
lecteur c'est pas grave
le but c'est d'aller jusqu'à la fin et
de prendre du plaisir à lire
ça s'appelle dans le cheval non dans le
ventre des choses 1 2 3 il ya les
mauvais mais il y en a eu beaucoup ce
que tous mes livres il y en a beaucoup
d'autres
ouais il y en a notamment qui sont
publiés et écrit spécialement pour les
enfants parce qu'un éditeur en sept font
ça pour les enfants alors celui là par
exemple sous la même étoile qui est
écrit par antoine dole et amélie dufault
a été commandée en fait qu libre et a
dit à antoine dole qui est quand même
auteur pour enfants assez connu lui a
dit écoutez nous on voudrait travailler
sur la difficulté ne et la difficulté en
parce que pour un enfant dyslexique
c'est c'est compliqué on confond les
deux donc trouver nous des mots qui se
termine par 9 des mots qui se termine
par an écrivez-nous deux histoires et on
va les publier
et vous voyez du coup le phonème ne et
en couleurs est comme ça l'enfant une
fois qu'il a lu ces deux histoires se
dit bah voila j'ai bien reconnu c'est
bien présent j'ai surmonté ces
difficultés et j'ai confiance on a vu
les éditions colibri l'ami des 10 c'est
un collection particulière ici fiq est
qui qui travaillent sur des difficultés
particulières donc il ya un roman un
livre pas difficulté ça peut être sûrs
au monde ça peut être sur neuf ça peut
être sûr que vous achetez le le roman
qui correspond à la difficulté que
traverse votre enfant est ce que des
héros ou des héroïnes finalement
dyslexiques parce que forcément les les
enfants et il s'accroche à ses héros et
s'il pouvait y en avoir un ou une ça
serait bien ça leur permettrait de ne
pas complexés ah oui alors y en a une
qui vient d'apparaître elle s'appelle
ambre c'est chez nathan et le livre
s'appelle la vraie vie de l'école
alors ce n'est pas ces livres là c'est
l'autre c'est celui là voilà pour lui de
ce que l'on attend je vous ai dit a été
très mobilisés sur la question eh bien
ils ont trouvé une héroïne s'est écrite
par pauline halfen et du cou et bien
cette héroïne là elle raconte sa vie en
tant que petite fille 10 et a dit que
c'est très difficile voilà
mais un jour encouragé par son frère
arthur elle se fait pas il se met à
écrire son journal intime comme elle a
des difficultés avec les conjugaisons
l'orthographe c'est voilà elle met des
notes dans la marge pour qu'on suive
toute son histoire mais son frère lui
dis c'est pas grave moi je corrige
vas-y l'important c'est d'écrire d'avoir
confiance en toi et de montrer que si on
est dyslexique
on peut quand même raconté son histoire
la vraie vie de l'école j'aime beaucoup
l'orthographe ou ici et je le conseille
pas ce que c'est accessible aux enfants
disent mais aussi à ceux qui ne le sont
pas pour comprendre voilà ce qu'on vit
quand on est un peu va voilà mis de côté
par la maîtresse qui comprend pas
c'est intéressant je vois notre pédiatre
qui est là marie laure d'alpha hacker
c'est parce que vous êtes aussi votre
quotidien vous envoyer des enfants
dyslexiques forcément oui bien sûr mais
il ya les enseignants font un gros
effort maintenant à des moments qu'on
reconnaît la difficulté l'enseignant va
adapter
effectivement la lecture l'enseignement
l'écriture et les parents seront mis
aussi au courant ils ne vont pas
culpabiliser donc ça c'est important
en tout cas la sélection livre de
typhaine est à retrouver sur le net et
sur les écrans connectés jeu